foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Jade
warshaw Ramsay personality is my co-host
today as we answer your questions about
your life and your money thank you for
joining glad you're here the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five the call is free and
some say the advice is worth exactly
what you pay for it Oliver starts off
this hour in Canada hi Oliver how are
you
hello Dave and Jade is an honor to speak
with you both how are you better than we
deserve how can we help
I am good uh I have a question it's kind
of complicated if so expand as best as I
can
um I'm going through the baby steps I've
been listening to you since 2017.
and uh I had made it to what I thought
was baby steps four and six I'm not sure
if I'm actually really there
um because
um me and my brother have a partnership
business it's a small business that we
do together and um back in 2018 I
foolishly took over
um some debt that he had created with a
lot of business expenses but it was on
his own credit card but still tied in
with the business
um because he was trying to be approved
for a mortgage so in order to get that
mortgage I had to well I didn't have to
but basically he had to get rid of that
debt out of his name and I foolishly put
it into my name
um I know that was a stupid thing to do
but that's what happened and basically
I was while doing my while doing my
budgeting since that time I'm like
as far as the bank is concerned that
debt is in my name now so that's my debt
even though I didn't create any of that
debt I was all my brother so I'm just
wondering on if I should
go about the baby steps by
sorry I'm just a bit nervous that's okay
um no dude it's real simple you're in
debt you're in baby step two yeah yeah
man it's a long convoluted crazy stupid
story how you got there but but you know
you're in debt how much is it Brandon
um
it's about let me see there's about 19
000 left okay and how much is in your
emergency fund
so I did have fourteen thousand
um which is another story I I had to
take about 4 600 just this past month in
January to pay myself because I wasn't
able to pay myself from the business
it's not the most profitable which is
another issue uh maybe I should talk
with call again about or call to call
Ken Coleman yeah but um there's about uh
2600 left in my emergency fund 2600 I
thought you started with 14 000 and took
out forty six hundred how did you get to
so let me check that
so
unless you were doing more with that
money you should have around 10 000 left
right if you only took 46
. so I'm just looking at my numbers here
um okay so here's the deal the business
went into it a couple times the business
based on the fact that your brother ran
into debt and they moved the debt over
to you and now you're having to use
money out of your savings to eat from
the business it doesn't sound like this
business is much fun
no it's not so let's go get a job
I'm doing a side hustle right now it's
not much but it needs to be a lot
flexible you need a job yeah you need
you need money to eat with and you don't
have money to eat with
well I don't know how to do that because
it's like me and my brother are the
owners I have employees it's a small
business I have three employees we've
either got to get the income up from the
business or we need to close it it's not
a business when it's losing money it's a
hobby
well that's the other issue I'm trying
to you know me and my brother don't
agree with
um certain things on the finances and
all of that and he he thinks credit
cards are fine even more reason even
more reason to close it have you ever
watched the show Shark Tank
yes and Mr Wonderful says you need to
take this business out back and shoot it
yeah I've already spoken with my brother
about you know I'm not enjoying the I've
told him very clearly I'm not liking how
this partnership is going even though I
care for him as my brother but um you
know I've already told him like oh
you're not you guys aren't making enough
money to run the business so it could be
you just turned the keys over to him and
let him have it
and then you go get you a job do what
I've told them that I would just start
my own business
you know being uh doing the same type of
business of what I'm doing now just make
just be the sole owner I've told him
that that's an idea I'm thinking about
you know to not have a partnership just
have me run my own business well
somewhere you've got to get money to eat
honey that's what I'm saying okay yeah I
hear you I hear you and then we and then
we can attack the 19 000 in credit card
debt that is now your credit card debt
because you just you decide to make it
yours so now it's yours and so there's
two issues on the table one is how do we
get out of your credit card debt of
nineteen thousand and the answer is
first thing we do stabilize our income
and get some income and then the second
thing is we're going to start the baby
steps which is a thousand dollars left
in your account because everything else
went to the nineteen thousand the credit
cards are cut up and closed and then you
attack them with a Vengeance with your
extra job your six extra jobs and you
you're side hustle and grind and then
you clean that mess up and you move on
but what all of this is doing
um sadly Oliver is it's going to make
you face
what you didn't want to admit
so my friend Henry Cloud wrote a book
called necessary endings
when is it necessary to end
a job a business a relationship it's
when there's no hope in the future in
your mind that it's going to get better
and so you know my boyfriend's does
drugs okay there's no hope that that's
going to get better is when you ax the
drug using boyfriend
gone right
if not sooner but uh absolutely but yeah
but I mean same thing with business when
do I close down a product line at Ramsey
it's when I lose hope that we can ever
make it work right until then I'll I'll
go at it you know but winners never quit
yes they do they quit doing stupid stuff
and yet another time when the facts are
your friends because you can look at the
bottom line you can look at the facts
over the course of the time of this
business and see hey like it's not
making money and it's not good for our
relationship I have a feeling Brandon I
think he loves the people that work
there and he wants them to be all right
and you know but still too late it's too
late too late you've lost control of
your ability to provide for them uh
because your brother's out of control
the business is not working you're not
making a living all of these things are
indicating indicating indicating this is
probably coming to an end unless you
have a reason
to have hope about the future but
everything you've told me doesn't give
me much hope for the business in the
future in the current state that it's in
and the way it's being run and
everything else so if you say okay these
three things change then I would have
hope okay then you can submit those
three things to be changed or the change
is going to be I'm out of here
that would be my choice
just being honest yeah it would be
pretty quick pretty quick only ship that
Won't Sail folks is a partnership this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
three things backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40 percent off everything
site-wise go to blinds.com for more
information
[Music]
well some of you survived the 300 days
of January
a long month or what it was so long that
a lot of you lost all the energy and
enthusiasm you had to get your life
straightened up so uh we're here to uh
remind you that you had energy and
enthusiasm to get your life straightened
up it just seems like a long time ago
hey you can make changes with your money
changes hard
but so is mediocrity
and that's why you got to have people
walking with you and that's why the
Financial Peace University classes have
been a game changer for about 10 million
people now and an FPU class you learn
our proven plan to get out of debt so
that you can build wealth and be
outrageously generous and you do it with
other people that are going over and
going through the exact same thing
hundreds of FPU classes are popping up
all across the country both online and
in person and you can sign up for an FPU
class go to ramseysolutions.com
FPU class
ramsesolutions.com FPU class you could
join Jades I hope that you do join mine
mine starts March 1st you can find it by
going to financial peaceuniversity.com
but there is a specialized link if you
are watching on YouTube you can click
that QR code we will also put the link
in the show notes and I'd love if you
joined our class it's going to be great
we are going to dive into all the stuff
ask me any questions and uh not only
that but we will have a q a the next day
on social media on my Instagram that you
can come in there and we'll answer
questions there as well so I'm excited
for you guys this is I tell Dave I gotta
say there's two things that I tell
people about all the time FPU and Jesus
they're the two biggest X factors of
life change and Sam and well I don't
tell them about Sam because Sam is mine
no no there's no share in there you do
tell them about it hey I will warn you
people do not join Jade's class unless
you're about doing this she loves you
well
and I'll let me Define that for you she
gonna knock the crud out of you if you
don't get yourself in gear oh yeah don't
don't come in talking about oh Jade it's
it's so hard I don't know no whining no
wine no whining with Jade because you
know what else is hard it's a no whining
Zone it's hard not being it's hard being
collected by bill collectors I can't
even get it out of my mouth it's so hard
you can't say it man it's hard to go to
the grocery store and not have enough
money for groceries it's hard it's hard
to be worried all the time it's hard
it's hard to not sleep well at night
because you've got she's gonna love you
so much that she's gonna
call wow the stuff and hey you're gonna
do it you're gonna do it this is a fun
thing I mean we work together we call
each other out and we lift each other to
another level you'll level up as you go
through this that's right and so
Financial Peace University
ramseysolutions.com click on FPU so
Blake Thompson was my very first
producer
on this show he's been with me 22 years
now and he now runs all of Ramsay
Networks and works here in the building
he's got a very very large crew
including all the booth people in there
running the show today and the ones on
every podcast that we do around here are
every
uh radio show that we do around here and
of course Blake and I started with the
uh the money game later the Dave Ramsey
Show now the Ramsey Show on radio
and he sent me an email this morning
that
just kind of blew my mind
so um
we have now tallied up and we are
billionaires
uh not net worth although maybe but uh
aside from that we now have had one
billion dollars
worth of debt
reduced in debt free screams alone
during the time we've been doing debt
free screams all added up all the people
just the ones on the air not all of you
that didn't come on the air but the ones
that did their debt free scream on the
air is now over a billion
dollars we have now had over 1 billion
podcast downloads
of this show
and we have now had over one billion
YouTube views
of this show wow we're three
billionaires
billion with a B wow that's just blows
my mind a billion downloads of this
podcast uh yeah we're in the top five
podcasts in the world literally uh
there's only a handful of people that
have had a billion downloads Joe Rogan
Me NPR a couple of others but uh that
that's about it but we've been on the
podcast scene since before podcasting
was cool and I've been putting what was
what was and is a radio show out over
that venue and that's where this comes
from a billion dollars of debt paid off
with a billion podcast downloads and a
billion YouTube views
that's a lot I'm just saying that's a
lot Brandon is with us Brandon's in
Atlanta how can we help you Brandon
hi sir congrats on the 1 billion
successes so here's one billionth time
you're gonna hear that I'm wrong and you
were right
um I got a dummy Express card about four
years ago I've been listening to you
since then I never took everything that
you said to heart but I did listen and I
kept paying off the American Express I
got to a point where I accidentally
racked up about eleven thousand dollars
in debt and credit card debt
um I'm down to 9 000 now I've been
taking you serious for the last three
months I have a budget I'm paying about
200 a month on it
um I've saved up though on the side
almost five thousand to put towards it
but right now my my job is in Jeopardy I
make about 70k a year
um after tax
my job has been in Jeopardy lately we're
just waiting on some contracts to hit
um do I put the 5000 and just go ahead
and start knocking down that debt or do
I hold it as an emergency fund just in
case I need to find another job
in Jeopardy sounds serious
like a 50 50 chance you lose your job
um about yeah around that or 60 40. I'm
hopeful but I don't want to use that as
much this is not vague worrying there is
a more than half chance you're going to
lose your job
uh possibly yeah you hold your cash then
okay until until you get your income
stabilized and you're not working the
baby steps all we're doing is piling up
cash
yes sir and you hold the cash you've got
you pile up other cash to get ready
because five thousand dollars not spit
you lose your job
and once those contracts hit if they do
and everything goes back to being stable
that's when I go back into the data then
you push play you push play again and
you empty everything out but a thousand
and you attack that card and 200 a month
when you're making seventy thousand is
Pretty stinking wimpy
yeah you got to get after it harder than
that you'll stay out of the restaurant
stay out of the restaurant
yes sir am I wrong
no you're completely right uh
lately with 70k of income he you're
doing a lot of restauranting and a lot
of mauling and a lot of whining and
dining it sounds like
yeah rent rents one up in my area
everything's went up for everybody so
that's not an excuse I can really use
but definitely once yeah
the interesting thing Brandon and you've
heard us say this because you've been uh
listening but not applying but let me
say it again just for you okay the thing
that we have all discovered in this
process is the angrier you get about
this the deeper you'll sacrifice
temporarily and then the faster you get
out of debt because the deeper you cut
your lifestyle the more money you throw
at the debt the faster you get out
mathematically but that has to do with
this visceral emotion that where you
start to be like uh okay I'm ready to do
it now no no no no no no this is like
okay and when you get that thing going
that's when you're gonna get like two
thousand dollars a month hey you got to
make it hurt you gotta cut it deep
because when you cut deep you you hate
you hate it and you hate that you have
to live like that in order to pay off
this debt and so you'll never do it
again you will vow to never put yourself
in that situation again
I open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five thank you for
joining us America we're glad you're
here and we do appreciate you guys the
fact that a billion of you have clicked
on a YouTube a billion of you have
downloaded the podcast thank you so much
it's Pretty stinking incredible
that's greatly honoring to us and it
makes us excited to come down here and
help you every day and to answer your
questions and to argue with you and all
the fun stuff we get to do here so thank
you thank you thank you
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today I'm Dave Ramsey your host
and this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
State and I want you to have a house but
I don't want a house to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today open
phone is a triple eight eight two five
five two two five I was being
interviewed on another podcast this
morning and the guy asked me jade he
said um so what has changed
over 30 years and I said well
Everything's changed over 30 years the
principles that we teach have not
changed at all but the there are new and
uh improved ways to do stupid absolutely
it comes out every year
and uh to to you know and sometimes they
rename old things and try to make them
sound like they're new and stupid uh but
they're still violating basic principles
so let me give you the basic principle
the basic principle is the shortest
distance between where you are and
wealth
is your greatest wealth building tool
which is your income when you pledge
your income to someone else in the form
of debt you slow down your ability to
build wealth and you add risk and
anxiety to your life
it's a very simple equation
zero debt leads you faster into wealth
than anything else you can do with money
the number of millionaires when we did
the largest study of millionaires ever
done in North America that said they
borrowed their way into
wealth was precisely zero
the number of them that said that their
airline miles on their card made them a
millionaire was precisely zero the
number of them that said but I became a
millionaire because I leased a car was
precisely zero the number of them that
said they became a millionaire because
they took out a whole life insurance
policy was precisely zero the vast
majority of them had avoided debt
completely or like the plague and it
kept their incomes freed up and caused
them to be able to invest I didn't have
any money for my 401k no but you have a
750 car payment idiot no wonder you
don't have any money for your 401k
thirteen hundred dollar car payment
that's right or here let's bring back an
oldie but a goodie now because
everybody's doing it again you know if
you hear those clothes if you keep them
long enough they'll come back in style
and the same is true is stupid so the
home equity loan is back yes home equity
line of credit HELOC the home equity
line of credit and uh life hacker says
I used one when I got in trouble so you
should everyone should have one in this
stupid butt article I remembered we'd
taken out a home equity line of credit
when we bought the house and it saved
our butts oh really oh really
his whole house is leveraged on this
money yeah so you know what do you know
what a homemade line of credit is
explain it for him Dave it's that
it's a second mortgage
and you know what they base the interest
rate on your credit nope whatever they
feel like when they wake up that morning
because it's variable it's completely
variable and it is not indexed to any
outside thing so Mr Banker says today
I think I'm going to charge Joe and
Susie stupid money
so you mean to tell me
in 2021 when I saw everybody in my
neighborhood
redo their yard redo their kitchen redo
everything and I'm going where is this
money coming from
it's because they took advantage of
their home equity they leveraged that's
the word I like Dave they leverage well
I'm I'm sophisticated because my My
Equity otherwise was not working for me
and now I have new bushes
[Music]
yeah that's that's what the you know and
that's what the banking ads sound like
don't they I mean if you listen if you
listen to Sofi oh yeah it's smart money
so smart money moves I'm just gonna so
if I throw up right here
oh my God man Dave I told you this
before the break it's a good thing
because I did so much stupid stuff
before I got a hold of of the principles
here if I had known about a HELOC thank
God I didn't know about this because I
would have just added it to the list of
dumb stuff right next to co-signing
alone yeah I want to put HELOC yeah well
here's the thing there's a lot of idiot
financial planners and people like
Lifehacker who will tell you to get a
home equity loan in case there's an
emergency now let's follow this line of
in air quotes logic
okay so you lose your job or you have
another Financial Calamity of some kind
so the home equity line is there to help
you you can go draw on it and you have
money
so at the moment that I've lost my job
or had a financial Calamity is precisely
the moment that I want to go deeper into
debt
this is the line of thought that's a
head scratcher yeah so I you know I've
had financial planners talk about this
for years and I've had to just rip their
rip them to shreds because it's just so
freaking stupid not all of them do this
but I mean someone will say open a home
equity line of credit don't use it and
use the fact that you can go tap into it
if you need to as your emergency fund
since I always tell them so what I want
what do I want to do when there's an
emergency what I want to do is add to
the anxiety and the stress by going
deeper into debt right you're turning it
dumber than Rock
oh my God it turns the emergency into a
crisis into a crisis because now you got
whatever it is that you're having to
deal with and you have to pay off the
debt and it's at a variable rate
of Interest so her point was is that
they had a uh they had a damaged storm
damage and they were able to use their
home equity loan to fix it because
apparently you don't know how to work
with your insurance company because if
you have storm damage and your roofs
leaking your insurance company will show
up start writing checks in about 36
minutes yeah
uh if you actually know how to talk to
them instead they didn't show up for you
you know why because you didn't need
them because you went into debt
yeah there's a lot underneath the
surface here on this article and let me
tell you what else happens every time
you do this crap right here okay house
gets torn up we use debt to fix the
house and we're going to pay off the
debt when the emergency when the
insurance check comes you know what you
always do a hundred percent of the time
people well 98 of the time people will
do more repairs to the house because
while we're at it we're gonna go ahead
and renovate then the insurance check
will cover so when the insurance check
comes it's not enough to cover because
we while we were at it we did some other
stuff yeah and that's what freaking
nature that's why I love in this article
he says the HELOC allowed us to get
started immediately that's what your
repair ZIP insurance won't show up when
the roof gets blown off your house yeah
I mean really if you have an insurance
company on homeowners that will not show
up and give you help immediately when
there's storm damage you have other
issues that a HELOC won't fix you know I
wonder what would happen if you just
saved up
for emergencies oh wait
you had money if you just saved up oh
there's an idea I wish I'd have thought
of that and you had the amount we should
we should do a radio show about that
that's awesome idea and in your three to
six months you had the amount of your
homeowners insurance deductible and you
didn't have any payments and so while
you're at work you're making money
without any payments and you have an
emergency fund and then when you have a
crisis you have this thing called
money
that's a great idea Jade and you just go
what is it that sucks all right write a
check yeah that's all you do Dave
emergency fund turns a crisis into an
inconvenience
and
a home equity loan turns a crisis into
an opportunity to be crisis squared
double up triple up exponentially worse
so here's the here's you're not
sophisticated if you used a home equity
loan to cover your problems in life
you're broke
and there's nothing sophisticated by
being broke it's just dumb
okay
just dumb now I've been dumb and I've
been broke so stop being dumb stop being
broke that we're going to walk you
through this and and you don't use well
I I'm I'm you know I'm utilizing the
equity in my home that otherwise would
not be working for me you're an idiot
okay when you say stuff like that you're
just an idiot because you are you're
truncating your most powerful wealth
building tool you're slowing your wealth
building down because you didn't have
any money to cover emergencies so
everyone should have an emergency fund
after they're out of debt except their
home baby step three of three to six
months of expenses we have been saying
that for 30 we've been saying that
longer than home equity loans have been
in existence they were not even in
existence when we started this radio
show 30 years ago they didn't make them
and now now we have a HELOC because
we're lucky sounds
I'm a financial person of a HELOC you
get a HELOC you get locked into debt
yeah that's about it you know what I I
think somebody ought to complain why
didn't they call it a she-lok
Dave don't go there yeah I think I just
got canceled somewhere in the universe
this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Stuart is in Atlanta
hey Stuart welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey Dave thank you guys so much for
taking my call sure what's up
um so just wanted to get your thoughts
on where my wife and I are at we are 32
years old
um our income is roughly 185 000 a year
and we're currently on baby step six and
my question is more around what we
should do over the next couple of years
so we are almost we are almost ready to
pay off our our house and over the next
couple of years we are going to want to
um you know to move to uh probably a
bigger house but my question is
more so around contentment because I
know that once we pay off our our house
we you know we won't have any other
payments and then my question I guess
revolves around should we take the next
three or so years and save up a really
big down payment to get the house that
we would live in you know forever I
guess you could say or should we
um not do that and instead just stay
where we're at in the current house that
we're in and just use the money that
we'll have every month you know to
invest more Etc yeah
um
well I mean there's a lot of different
ways you can get at this
um first let's just dispel the idea that
there is such a thing as a forever house
I'm 63 I've had four forever houses so
far
I keep thinking there forever and
they're not
um Sharon and I are planning to build
another house right now and she says
well this I'm gonna build this because
I'll probably die in this that's not a
chance
unless you're not quick I mean it's just
because we're we're not going I mean we
we're just we're 10 12 years 13 years
and we move on the next one I mean so uh
maybe maybe not but so all of that's
aside you got a really good question you
put yourself in a wonderful position
congratulations you make a lot of money
uh you're debt free you're being very
wise you're thinking about things which
makes you also wise most people just do
crap and then wonder how to clean it up
and you're just doing really really good
stewards so this is more of a discussion
of smart or smarter
okay it's there's no Dom in this
discussion okay so just just way to go
dude way to go so if you live there and
you you're gonna pay off the is it paid
off now or it's almost paid off
it's almost paid off we should be making
our final payment this month oh way to
go and what's that house worth
um probably around 220 225. way to go
good for you okay and then you're going
to want to move up sometime in the next
few years to a house that is worth maybe
what
uh we were we were thinking probably
around 500. okay so double okay she need
you need 300 Grand and you make 180.
right
yep okay so I just do big math in my
head is the way I do it if I'm looking
at this stuff to start to see how I can
emotionally swallow this or not okay is
it going to take me 10 years or is it
going to take me 20 minutes you know
that's what I'm always looking at and so
um in your case if I did 100 a year for
three years you're there right and you
live on 80. right you live on 80. so
that's one kind of contentment
um another kind of contentment is you
live in the current home you're in for
the rest of your life a lot of people do
that
um another kind of contentment would be
to go ahead and sell your house now buy
the 500 550 000 house put the uh whole
Equity from your current home into it
and then turn around pay it off in three
or four years with your great income
none of these are in the dumb column
now I I will tell you this if you pay
off your home
the way you've been intentional about
this the words you're using how dialed
in you are the Ramsay stuff and you sit
there in a paid for home till Christmas
I will tell you from personal experience
it's going to be very hard to take on a
payment again and swallow it and get
that down your throat yep
yeah that's what we've thought about too
it's up to you I'm just saying it really
tastes especially bad the second time
yeah it's like getting to swallow your
food the second time no that's gross you
know so uh yeah it's just hard uh you
know again
is anybody who can put down enough money
and pay off their home in three years
stupid no
no you're not even close I mean you're
just in great shape so any of these are
fine or you can kind of meet in the
middle Sharon we don't borrow money so
we would have to wait and save it up
Sharon and I but we don't yell at people
on the Ramsey Show for taking out more
than a 15-year mortgage where the
payments no more than a 15 or a fourth
of your take-home pay and you're nowhere
even near that side of the equation so
you could actually land in the middle
and say okay we're going to live here
one year and put another hundred
thousand in the bank
and then we're going to do it and so and
then we're going to pay it off in two
years we're going to live here two more
years and put 200 000 in the bank and
pay it off in one year to be honest with
you Dave I I you know that third option
that you gave you said regardless Stuart
whether you save up for three years or
it's such a small period of time too
because I'm the type three years I'm
like oh if we're gonna pay it off in
three years anyway I'd rather live in it
while we're paying it off but these are
the these are great problems to solve
because like Dave said there's no
stupidity here it's just it's just
options and if you make that final home
payment and you're like I like this I
will never go back into debt again then
wait it out but for those people
listening I do think it's important to
hear that you pay off you pay off one
home you're not a bad person if you go
back and get a small mortgage again to
move up in house what I will tell you is
this don't start looking at 550 000
houses after you've looked at 750 000
houses
that won't work
so just don't even go over there
don't even go over there because you can
actually pull that off too but you gave
me these guidelines that's a good point
I would hold you to those in the name of
contentment
because I didn't give you the number you
gave yourself the number so stick to it
because I got to tell you you look at a
million dollar house they're great until
you look at two men
you know you know what's nicer than a
fifty thousand dollar car a hundred
thousand dollar car yeah I mean it's
just but don't go drive one unless
you're gonna be buying one yeah so yeah
stay at stay out of that neighborhood
don't go to open houses I just want to
see what the colors know oh no I don't
play yourself no no no I won't feel like
no you don't stay away from there hey
Stuart you're doing good man
congratulations Tom's in Peoria Illinois
hey Tom what's up
a day long time follower uh first time
caller here for you thanks uh
really appreciate you taking the call
here uh just want to get your idea here
for me uh I'm kind of in a unique
situation I am 56 years old my wife is
52 years old
uh we live we are completely debt free
uh our house is paid for
uh following your Steps early on in life
here starting in my 30s
our first home we took out a small
mortgage for it was I shouldn't say
small
is a 15-year loan uh we paid it off in
five
uh we saved up for approximately five
more years living at that home
comfortably until we started having
children
okay what's your question for a run out
of time
uh just want to know uh I'm a big car
guy and I have quite a few collector
cars here and just want to know what you
thought is classic cars as an asset for
later on live to cashing in on value as
I don't know if you follow the cat the
collected car market at all I've got a
1970 frame up restro or 1960 frame up
restro uh Corvette so yeah I got one got
one of them so uh the uh I was born in
1960 so I wanted a 1960. so yeah I'm in
I'm in I'm in the business uh the thing
about Collectibles is uh they're so
dependent it's such an a weird Market
it's such an imperfect Market it's an
unpredictable Market
um and uh it's more dependent on your
expertise than it is actually the market
is how much money you end up making on
one they're an asset for sure and they
do increase in value if you did a decent
one for sure that car has probably gone
up some in value since I bought it uh
but but uh I don't I tell people of
Collectibles of any kind fine art wine
collection I've got a gun collection uh
you know they're all assets because I
got money tied up in them but uh they
shouldn't be more than 10 of your net
worth
because then you're betting the farm so
to speak on that category and so it's
okay and you can make a little money on
it and it's a great hobby that goes up
in value that's fun and you got the
margin because you got the money I would
do it but just limit it limit the value
to about 10 percent of your net worth of
or somewhere around there and you'll be
okay that puts this hour the Ramsey Show
in the books
foreign
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting for the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Jade wash
all Ramsay personality is my co-host
today open phone is a triple eight eight
two five five two two five you jump in
we'll talk about your life and your
money jarixa is with us in Boston hey
terexa what's up
yes hi thank you for taking my call our
pleasure how can we help
so
for a while and I was starting to save
out of debt and doing all that stuff and
obviously I had to have a play in his
car so I was thinking about it but not
willing to but then I had an insurance
problem and they realized or I realized
that I had points in my life a lot so my
insurance went up to 600
um a month plus my car now it's like
450. your insurance went up to 600 a
month
yes oh why
um I have five points on my license that
I didn't realize until I updated my life
and buy my insurance
okay
wow so now the penalty 35 months for it
um so I have that and then I have my car
payment which I know was kind of stupid
it was it's 450. so my idea was to get
rid of a car because my kids schools are
distance where I can walk them
um and then get an the only issue is I
work in my car I do Uber but I just feel
like it's not worth it anymore so it
would make more sense for me to get a
real job or something else I guess
um and I won't have a cargo but I have
the t station across from my house like
right there I think you have a great
plan
I think that's a great plan
I guess my question is
how what to like how to go about it I do
have
I don't know if it's
taking advantage or but I do live in
like Section 8 Housing and I have a lot
of like government assistance so I know
the goal will be to move up and away so
I do have a few options and I guess that
was my question do I lower my rent and
take two part times and then start
career searching and you know figure out
how old are you for
seven and then I have two kids I'm a
single mom of two kids
and I'm 27. hmm
okay um you got your hands full
okay
listen let's back up whoa whoa stop stop
stop let's back up okay one of the
you're asking really really good
questions after you got this really
Stern wake-up call from your insurance
company
uh and you're it's kind of shook you and
you're you're really re-looking
everything and that's very wise that's
very smart so the one of the things I
learned many many years ago I read a
piece of research that said that rich
people when they're making decisions
think about
how it's going to affect them 20 years
from today
poor people think about how it's going
to affect them Friday
and I've been both by the way
I've been the Thank God It's Friday oh
God it's Monday very barely hanging on
by my fingernails where you are right
now
and so what I learned to do is I said if
I want to be rich people rich people
don't make decisions because that way
because they're rich they're rich
because they make decisions that way and
so what we want to do is increase the
planning window and so when I run into
someone in your case and you're a very
inspiring young woman I think you're
going to really be somebody someday
I want to ask myself 10 years from today
where do I want to be and which of these
decisions take me there
because if you're not careful you make
short-term decisions which keep you in a
short-term situation if you make
long-term decisions let me tell you what
almost always happens they're almost
always painful now and awesome later
short-term decisions are almost always
awesome right now but painful later
because I'm stuck
does that make sense to you
yes so what's the best career path for
you that makes you
have an amazing life 20 years from today
and what are the steps along that ladder
that are there and what's the first step
of that even if it's a a painful step or
something you don't want to do right now
and it feels icky right now but by you
know by uh by summer we'll start to see
the light a little bit and then by the
next summer really start to see the
light a little bit and so on and so you
know an example of that is Uber is a is
a is a valid good side hustle it's not a
real good long-term career play agreed
I I yes I finally agree with that yeah
so I mean even if your car even if your
car insurance hadn't gone up you don't
want to be if you're 27 now you don't
want to be a 57 year old Uber driver
in in flying cars or whatever right but
I mean it's that that's not a good
long-term place so what is our long-term
play what do we want to be and what are
the steps to get there what must be true
about you and your life that's not true
about you and your life today to get you
there and when Sharon and I went broke
and lost everything and we had a little
baby and a toddler and we were so scared
we couldn't breathe and the electricity
got cut off and the water got cut off
because I didn't pay the bill because I
didn't mean money I had to stop and
think hey I got to get those turned back
on but B what do I do so that I'm never
here again
and I started asking myself those
questions and that's how a lot of the
principles on this show were born so
we've got three issues on the table
today we need to make decisions about
with a long-term mindset career housing
and transportation
yes okay long term riding the Subway or
the bus is not going to make you wealthy
that's right
short term it might enable you to save
up and pay cash for a two thousand
dollar car and your insurance won't be
much on a two thousand dollar car
okay so maybe we do that for a little
while long term living in subsidized
housing obviously is not going to make
you wealthy
but short term it might give you the
footing to take some steps towards
getting out right
yes so we start setting some dates and
stuff in front of us of where we're
going to go from there yeah you know
jurix uh the situation that you're in I
I relate to in some ways and there's
something about kind of feeling rock
bottom right you feel like you're at the
bottom but now the way to go is up right
there you know necessity truly is the
mother of invention and sit down like
Dave said and really start looking
through okay what can I do I want to
give you uh Ken Coleman's uh paycheck to
purpose and start thinking through all
right what can I do with myself
career-wise what will that look like
with child care and really start putting
this I don't want it floating around in
your mind I want you writing these
things down on paper and creating a
clear plan what you're going to do
before I let you go let me right quick
I'm gonna jump in on you Jade I'm gonna
give you so much stuff it's going to be
unbelievable because I think you're
awesome and I want you to go do
everything we tell you to do I'm going
to put you in Financial Peace University
we're going to sign you up for Ken
Coleman's career assessment we're going
to send you his book on payche the
purpose that Jade was talking about I'm
going to send you my book a Total Money
Makeover I want you to work six extra
jobs I want you to stay in that place
right now and get you a two thousand
dollar car by one year from today I want
you out of there and I want you in a
decent full-time job taking you towards
your career your short-term steps to get
to your long-term goals hold on we'll
pick up we're going to give you a
thousand dollars worth of stuff right
there kiddo but do everything we said
and call us back and let us know how it
goes
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to nest tweet.com Ramsay today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you for joining us America I'm
Dave Ramsey your host
so 27 year old single mom with two kids
52 percent of single moms in America
live below the poverty level and she's
probably right close
yeah and the
the reason I just dumped all this stuff
on her is it's my best shot to help her
uh and so
the interesting thing is is that um
over 30 years of doing this I have met
I'm
not exaggerating when I say thousands of
people who have
taken basic financial principles like
we're talking about looking long term
saving money
uh not because when you look short term
you take out a big car payment because
the car smells nice right I mean she's
living in subsidized housing as a 400
car payment see that's 450 that's what
keeps you there yeah and so um
but but the opposite of that is what we
started describing and what she had
already come to in her own wisdom uh but
but
the story for you in America is that you
can go from there to millionaire
your bad break can become Your Big Break
and it is about applying the principles
and thinking long term and
um
it's like a buddy of mine who who grew
up in a really rough neighborhood he's
uh said it's easier to get out of the
hood and just get the hood out of you
you know and I it's it's easier to get
out of the old neighborhood whatever
your old neighborhood is because how
many times have any of you out there
listening to me have heard or even said
these words uh
People Like Us
yes Dave dot dot dot the first time I
ever ran into it and I thought it was so
humorous because I was I'm of course a
southern redneck hillbilly right yeah
yep and uh
about as white as white can be right and
so I I thought redneck people like me
were the only ones that did stupid butt
stuff with car payments so I I you know
start to get a little bit of traction
and other people are inviting me to
speak and I end up in New York City
speaking this group of people there
there was about a thousand people in the
audience and it was pretty much the
United Nations yeah I mean there's every
color every stripe every background
every uh accent except mine yeah in in
the audience right and so I was pretty
entertaining to them with my hillbilly
accent right but uh when I got off the
stage and started signing I was cracking
up because this lady comes up to me and
she goes but you don't understand
I'm Puerto Rican and I'm like I'm sorry
I don't know what that means I mean I
know what a Puerto Rican is but I don't
know what you're talking about she goes
all Puerto Ricans have to have a big car
payment no we have to have a nice car
and I'm like darling that's not a Puerto
Rican disease that's a human disease
I mean people like us I'm probably
getting ready to get myself canceled but
I hear it all the time Jade the system
is set up for people like us to fail
that is not an African-American thing
that's not a Puerto Rican thing that is
not even a redneck white guy thing I
mean it's because I heard that you know
the little man can't get ahead people
like us but the corporations I I got a
relative to the corporations the
corporations I'm like what are you even
talking about look look yes there are
things there are obstacles to overcome
for anybody for anybody their sexism
there's racism there's ageism there's
all these things but you're more limited
by your own mindset than you are limited
by anything systemic because it's like
what you said I can get out of the hood
but I didn't get the hood out of me all
right you know those are the things
that's a mindset but the thing I was
thinking about with her is she can do
this she can I the problem is I believe
she can do it maybe more than she does
right now and that's because she's not
got anybody around her going you can do
this that's right she's not hanging out
with people that are doing it she
doesn't have a community around her
going lifting her arms up saying you got
this you got this you got this so we
tried in just a moment there to be your
community and love her and jump a bunch
of things on her but guys
you can do this she is going to have to
be very intentional about changing her
own mind and because we we poured it
into her but she's got to keep filling
her mind with I can do this I can
overcome this I can earn money I can get
out I'm so
it's for me it is for me Financial Peace
is for me too not just the people on TV
not just the Joneses not just the folks
over there financial pieces for you
being debt free is for you not just
those folks over there so I hope she
believes that there are idiots that will
hold you back
for some stereotypical reason
um again racism is real sexism is real
regionalism Israel I I have people that
wouldn't put me on the radio because
they thought with a Southern accent I
must be broadcasting from a double wide
not wearing shoes but that doesn't mean
that that's true it just means that's an
ignorant person a hundred percent of
racists are ignorant people 100 of
sexist or ignorant people and you know
that's ridiculous uh and so you can't
let ignorant people make your decisions
for you and set up your the boundaries
by which you run your life and so it
just I
you know
the first thing I did was when I was a
kid I got indoctrinated my parents got
in the real estate business with the
Positive Thinking movement and then I
kind of got uh that's just overdone and
it is overdone yeah uh sometimes but I
mean you can't positive think your way
into anything but you can't negative
think your way into anything right right
you can't a positive think your way into
everything but you can't negative think
your way into anything that's good David
and you can you got to have new
information continuing to do the same
thing over and over again expecting a
different result and blaming it on
someone else is part of what you're
doing yeah is the definition of insanity
so this that's why we get so angry
around here and passionate about victim
thinking she didn't have Victory she did
not no she I mean she called scratching
and clawing trying to figure out a way
yeah but
some people look at her situation go
well the problem is not her the problem
is the systemic problems in the economy
and the the the whole back of a lady
like that yeah they're there they're
there but you've heard me say it Dave
she can do it you can't blame your way
to a better life those are all things
that you can blame that'll tweet but at
the end of the day you can build your
way to a better life you can believe
your way you can behave your way you
cannot blame your way and I love that
she called here because she's tired she
wants to do something different and she
can so the reason I'm going off on the
soapbox is for all of you that are
listening you actually can help people
and you don't help them by giving them a
government program
you help them by showing them the way
out and putting your arm around them and
walking with them on their way out yep
and so those of you that are using our
materials in uh halfway houses where
people are working their way out of
prison those of you that are using our
materials in domestic violence housing
uh that are letting those ladies get a
new life after they decided after
they've got in a situation where they're
no longer a punching bag those of you
that are using our materials in uh
subsidized housing situations or in
lower income whatever you want to call
it situations homeless shelters a lot of
them we send them stuff all the time
those of you that are doing that it
works
thank you
you are the answer to these peoples to
folks in that situation
that the reason I'm not broke anymore is
because people love me enough to put
their arm around me and show me a
different way I didn't figure it all out
in my own head I know that's right I'm
here because y'all came alongside me
without even knowing you without even
knowing me it's it it's the material
like he said if you if you are putting
this message out there you have no idea
uh the domino effect that you're
creating so there's a power to hope that
supersedes
ignorant people
that are in ISM if you're an ism you're
an ignorant person
and you're in the way
and so if you're engaging in an ism
that's your problem and there's the
power that supersedes that is Hope and
that's not some kind of false Panacea
positive thinking way the truth is when
you believe that you can go do stuff so
you go do it that's when you get there
but when you believe you can't do it
then you don't go do it and and so when
someone says well it's a systemic I want
to smack them because you're a hope
stealer when you do that you're a hope
stealer when you allow someone to blame
something on someone else instead of
going after the dad blame solution grab
it by the throat that's yours oh God
she's inspiring to me I love it she's
gonna be awesome hey we need to follow
up with her I already got her email Dave
I'm already on it you're on it all right
you're a step ahead of me this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more first
[Music]
[Applause]
open phones this hours we talk about
your life and your money this is the
Ramsay show thank you for joining us I'm
Dave Ramsey Jade warshaw Ramsey
personality is my co-host today huh
Justin's with us in San Antonio hi
Justin welcome to the show
hey Dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
um
well so
my question is I well first of all I'll
start off in love at the beginning of
December my wife passed away
we have two uh
two young children a one-year-old and a
six-year-old and uh what happened
well she had cancer I'm so sorry she uh
she was diagnosed when the my son was
six weeks old oh my gosh and uh she's
been fighting it ever since in a couple
of years huh
uh it was just over a year she was
admitted on uh you know on Thanksgiving
and
on Thanksgiving to the day she was back
in how old was she Justin
31. yes sir and what was her name
Caitlin I'm so sorry
wow yeah it was it was uh
it's been a you know obviously not what
we expected but you know we're
we're here
um one day at a time yes
yes and for I mean I've been listening
to you for 15 years we were married for
eight
um and uh so we're debt free we don't
have any debt other than uh our home
and so I have a plan with you know his
life insurance money and things like
that have been coming in
um there is enough there plus what we
already had saved and stuff like that to
pay off the house
um and that's it we owe you know we own
everything just his house
um one thing we have debt on so
obviously my plan was to do that
um it was a house that we built it was
her Greenhouse so
kind of point me in that direction to
use the money for that
um we have other money as well but just
specifically that money
um I just wanted to know you know some
advice or if I should
in your opinion if I should just wait or
you know if you need any more
information to judge that well
um
ah
wasn't my wife I never met her and I
still can't breathe just talking to you
so I can't imagine what you're going
through
um
uh
what we suggest folks do if possible
in the lot in the loss of a loved one is
to wait six months before you make any
major financial decisions
and let some of the
the biggest and early waves of grief
clear so that your mind is thinking
clearer nothing you have said indicates
that you're unclear nothing you've said
sounds weird you sound like you're
processing this whole thing properly and
you've you know you've been fighting it
with her for a year so it wasn't like it
was a a shock or something so you've had
a a period of time to work through some
of the emotions at least partially okay
but there's no harm no foul in parking
the money in a CD for six months and
just crying
right and then you'll uh you'll always
hurt from this But as time goes along
you'll think clearer and clearer and
clearer and clearer Sharon and I've been
married 40 years if she died the first
of December I would not be thinking
clearly right now I can just tell you
and uh my my brain would be in a total
fog and so
um
I love the idea of doing nothing and I
think that's a possibility for you
um it's not horrible to pay off the
mortgage but it's also not horrible to
just wait a few months and just breathe
given that it was your dream home with
her
she was involved in the building of it
and it might be painful to live there
you might discover that a year from now
I don't know did she pass away at the
hospital or at home
at the hospital okay
so that that makes keeping the home
a better idea it might be harder where
she there right
um right yeah I mean it's mainly she's
you know everything was too designed for
our children so yeah well you see you
see her fingerprints every time you turn
a corner though
oh I mean you know yes we were Picture
People we have pictures everywhere well
you don't have those I hope you have
those forever but I'm sure I'm just
saying I'm saying I don't want the house
to be a cause of pain and you kept it
only because you paid it off you follow
me I don't think that's going to be the
case I don't hear anything here that
indicates that but a little bit of time
will be clearer on that if you can wait
four five six months and park that money
in a CD and do do as little decision
making as you can and just give yourself
some room to cry
um you'll make a better decision six
months from now than you will make now
you might make exactly the same decision
and that'll be okay
but it but it'll be made from a clearer
mind that's my only suggestion
yes sir I agree I agree wholeheartedly I
think that taking the time and just
settling
is is the way to go and like Dave said
you're probably going to end up making
the the same choice but at least you'll
know it was from a place of clarity and
not just from that place of because I
think sometimes when things like this
happen you're just I gotta do something
I gotta do something you know
right yeah I'm sorry Justin absolutely
hey man yeah I appreciate it well we're
honored to to be part of your family and
that you call us in the worst moment of
your life and that we
um get to be there with you and walk
with you that's powerful
huh and if you need anything else we're
still here you call back six months from
now if you want to talk about it again
we'll talk about it I'll probably
remember that call
Alicia's with me in Boise Idaho welcome
to the Ramsay show Alicia what's up
hey Dave thanks for taking my call sure
how can I help hey I've got a question
um I am currently on baby steps four and
seven
um I am looking to potentially my goal
is four and seven your house is paid for
yes sir
negative but it's not my forever home
and I plan on selling it
okay there's no such thing as four and
seven that's why I was asking so you're
just on baby step four and six she has a
mortgage well
yeah okay okay yes sir all right I'm
just trying to understand what's going
on all right okay I'm back with you now
well you're writing a whole new script
for these baby steps I was trying to
catch up okay
completed we'll check marks that but
um five and six
six well okay six I have still I have a
mortgage that I am paying on correct
correct
um I currently have my goal is to build
my forever home there's no such thing a
year no
I've lived in four forever homes
all right life changes in your life
changes and you're going to move again
but you want to move up in house and get
your cool house I'm okay with that part
okay yes yes I do and I want to build it
good and I want to at least have 50 of
that cost saved up good cool
I have 125
000 sitting in the bank right now way to
go
what I would like to know is where can I
stick that to generate its own not
income but like build off of it
so it's sitting there making at least a
little bit more than what it's sitting
in my regular bank account how long
before you break ground on the house
um as of right now my projection is next
year
okay depending upon the market and how
all the material and cost is going to be
but right now I'm projecting 2024.
and then projecting to try to get to
200k good for you you're awesome and how
much Equity is in your current home
um I've got about 80 in equity eighty
thousand so when you sell it you'll have
another 80 should be 280 in what's the
house going to cost your own bill
so you're gonna have a mortgage under
200 Grand 150 200 Grand and you're going
to pay that off in just a couple of
years you're a rock star way to go so
you cannot there the only thing I do
with money on the short term is put it
in something like an index fund like an
S P 500 Index Fund that's whatever the
stock market does in one year you could
lose five percent you could gain ten
percent it's probably not worth it I
would just shop around and try to get a
little bit more with a money market or
some kind of CD for one year hysa you're
not gonna I would rather it be safe for
you the way your mind works after
talking to you than I would you try to
make more on it and so if you make two
percent instead of one percent that's
okay but you're not gonna make ten
percent without taking risk I don't want
you to take
this is a Ramsay show
[Music]
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host let's face it taxes are
confusing we hate them
and if you buy into some of the tax
service ads out there you'll believe
you'll never get a grasp on taxes and
you shouldn't even try and so let us
take care of you
or they'll suck you into offers that
won't help you win with money and here's
a here's a good tax tip for you today
a tax refund is not a bonus
it's a re
fund it's your money that you paid in
too much to the government and then
drunk uncle see Steve sometimes known as
Uncle Sam sends it back to you with no
interest
so if you get a big tax refund it's
nothing to cheer about it means you
calculated your withholding wrong
that's all it means you loan them money
interest free all year and then they
send it back to you Santa Claus I know
him personally does not live in D.C
not there baby there's your tax tip all
right so if you hadn't already filed and
you're ready to work with a service you
can trust got complicated taxes get a
Ramsey trusted tax Pro on your side
they'll walk you through it if you've
got a complicated return if you've got a
basic return use the Ramsey smart tax
software it's really cheap really easy
to do boom and we're not going to try to
sell you a credit card like TurboTax
um you didn't disguise that very well
Dave I didn't I thought I was coughing
there but um
yeah they're owned by into it and um to
show your credit card and try to get you
alone on your refund
so that you're happy you got a refund so
now you got a loan with them instead of
just doing your stinking taxes all this
crap around doing your taxes smart tax
Ramsay smart tax just does the taxes you
don't do nothing else it's kind of
boring so ramseysolutions.com tax check
out our Ramsay trusted tax pros and the
Ramsay smart tech software depending on
whether you got a complicated or a
simple return we can help you either way
and no hidden gotchas we have no other
agenda we just want you to do this and
no more refunds geez people come on
ramseysolutions.com
taxgeter done Chad's with us in San
Antonio hey Chad welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hey Dave thanks for taking my call sure
man what's up
um
so I'm a fairly new listener and
um recently I just took a traveling uh
job
and we we moved from Arizona and we we
travel uh throughout the country
um and who's we I'm
oh me and my wife okay she works remote
so she's able to work
um that sounds like an adventure cool
it's great so
um rather than staying in hotel rooms or
airbnbs or short-term rentals we decided
to purchase we sold our home and
purchased a a travel trailer
so
um we have a note on that of
approximately seventy thousand dollars
and
um my question for you is do we let the
bank float up and continue to make
payments
or is paying something like that off
um a priority
we don't we don't have any kids um
um no actually we I mean how much money
maybe three or four thousand
I've got about ninety thousand dollars
saved but we're trying to have kids this
year so I haven't cost ninety thousand
dollars to have a kid either sell the
trailer or pay it off today
okay if you're not willing to pay it off
you need to sell it
okay you want to know why you wanna know
why you wanna know why I want to know
why there's stupid things going down in
value like a rock
would you pay for it
uh 130 and you bought it new
yes sir you know it's going to be worth
in five years don't you
about what I owe on it yeah no
no in five years it's worth 30. lower
you lost a hundred thousand dollars
over five years
that's what this did
so if you're going to keep it you got to
pay it off
was it a smart option to do this other
than to stay in airbnbs I just felt like
that was throwing money out the out the
window I don't think it would have cost
you a hundred thousand dollars
because you're paying payments plus
losing a hundred thousand dollars
right
so no it was not it was not a smart move
but you're there now I'm not I mean you
know so here's the thing you're getting
ready to have kids sometimes you're
probably going to sell it and settle
down the sooner you sell it and settle
down
uh the less Financial damage you've got
so were I doing this over if you really
were bent on what you're doing I
probably would have bought the thirty
thousand dollar used one and towed it
around and let it turn into ten fifteen
thousand dollars and that would have
been much more palatable you bought a
freaking Bentley took behind your truck
130 Grand
our lifestyle we've been we've been
camping and traveling and and doing
off-road Sports so it kind of made sense
you're not even listening
if you well you lost a hundred and
thousand dollars Chad
that's what this just you overbought you
completely stepped in it and it's all
over your shoe and shaking your shoe at
me is not going to get it off no it's
still there
oh my gosh so these trailers it's just
like with a car they're losing 60 of
their value within the first boats and
trailers go down faster than cars
and it's painful and RVs are the worst
they're the worst of the worst so
whatever you put into a boat a camper or
an RV you need to be able to set that
amount of money in the middle of the
floor and set fire to it and it'd be
okay
because that's basically what you're
doing now I have a couple boats and the
same situation yeah but I can afford to
set fire to that much money and it not
affect my life uh Chad can't afford to
lose a hundred thousand dollars so Chad
if I were in your shoes if you're going
to keep it and I don't think you're
going to get rid of it based on talking
to you for two minutes you're probably
going to keep it because you're really
sold out on this whole idea uh I I would
pay it off at a minimum at least then
you've admitted what you've done and you
feel it okay and you don't have the
payments anymore so now we take the
payments and you start rebuilding your
money so that you can buy a home and
settle when you have kids because you're
um and the sooner you do that the less
this is going to go down in value
because I'm talking five years out that
130 is going to be worth 30. oh that's
painful
and uh so I mean that that's where we
are and and but if you if you sell it
now you probably can sell it for what
you owe on it yeah but uh but you're
probably gonna run this plan for a
little while longer I doubt one phone
call to Dave Ramsey is going to change
all this so um that that's the plan but
yeah that's what I would do if I were in
your shoes the good news is you have the
money in the account and you can pay it
off
Annie's in Phoenix hey Annie what's up
hi thanks for taking my call sure what's
up um I have a question so my job that I
work at they give us stocks and
um they've been giving us stocks for the
last five years that I've been working
there I've never really done anything
with it they just announced they're not
gonna give us stocks anymore so I'm like
okay I should do something with it I'm
wondering if I just sell them and then
pay off my car
and then just like from there snowball
into my credit card
um bet or if I should just ignore it and
leave it and let it grow or I'm not sure
what that works to be honest and sell my
car to pay off my credit card debt I
liked your first idea if I had a bunch
of company stock I probably liquidated
in order to pay off debt only because
it's single stocks you know it's not
your long-term play for investing and I
don't know what company you work for I
don't know how stable they are but if
something were to happen you know with
the company the value of the stocks
could easily go down so that's what I
would do yeah sell it and if you got
enough to pay off your car and your
credit card's great if not pay off your
smallest debt to your largest debt and
then take any money that's freed up in
any money you can squeeze out your
budget and finish off the rest of the
debts you want to have a goal Annie of
being debt free as fast as you can
because your most powerful wealth
building tool is your income and the
faster you're not giving it to someone
else for buying stupid stuff with money
you don't have to impress people you
don't really like the faster you're
going to become wealthy and that's the
process so yes definitely liquidate that
today
um and it's just it's a bonus money you
got a Bonus at work you got bonus at
work what are you gonna do with it I'm
gonna use it to get out of debt that's
what I'm doing good question Annie thank
you for the call
that puts this hour of the Ramsey Show
in the books
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love to create
actual amazing relationships Jade wash
all Ramsey personalities my co-host
today it's a free call a triple eight
eight two five five two two five thank
you for joining us America we're so glad
you're here Rachel is with us Rachel is
in Detroit hi Rachel welcome to the
Ramsay show
hi Dave thanks for having me today sure
what's up
okay so I have a question me and my
husband are completely debt-free except
for a house
and it's actually a career question
um I've been working at this medical
office for probably almost a decade and
um I love my boss I love the job I love
everybody I work with and I love ours
however I have never got a raise
since I've been there and there is no
benefit as far as like 401K medical
anything like that 10 years without a
raise
yes I've been there almost 10 years
without a raise yeah have you asked him
about that
well this is the thing
um
uh one of one of my co-workers just left
the office after being there for a long
time
and
um he called me up and he said that he
was going to give me a raise
if I stayed with him until retirement
and I said oh okay you know so I when I
went to work I gave it about two weeks
when I went to his office and I said
um oh I was just wondering what happened
to that race that
um you said something to me about and he
said oh I'm not going to do that until I
actually tell you I'm retiring
and I'm like oh okay
like I don't know why you would say it
right if you're not gonna give me the
raise I guess
and so I don't know what to do in this
situation because a part of me my
husband's telling me that I should go
look for another job and then a part of
me is like well maybe I should stay here
but he is going to be retiring I don't
have a retirement day I don't have
anything another job just
um asks is gonna offer is going to be
offering me a job what do you make
um
an hour or what do you make a year
I make about
30 000. okay and what do you do
I'm a receptionist it's something I
don't I don't have to work but I want to
work because I want to pay your house
off faster
okay what's the uh where do you want to
be doing in 10 years
good question
you want to keep working for the next 10
years doing something
yeah okay I do I do want to work any
other place that offered you less money
why did they offer you less money than
thirty thousand dollars The Other Place
offered me a dollar less but they have
benefits but then I'd be working more
hours
and I don't know what to do do you want
to work
no I don't but I want to make sure it
sounds like neither one of these are
good jobs
look for a different one you kind of
boxed yourself into a corner and told
yourself it's either this or that and
that there's no other options out there
but there are other options out there if
you if you keep casting your net out
there
you might poke around and make 50 000
doing customer service somewhere
might not be might not be as a
receptionist but you might just there's
so many there's such a labor shortage
right now it's a great time to be
looking for a position
and um you know so uh yeah I think I
think I would slip into your doc's
office first is that's who you're
dealing with a doc right yes and they're
notoriously horrible at running
businesses
um so I in leadership and those kinds of
things because what he what he just did
like violated like 73 leadership rules
okay so yes I would just slip in there
and say you know I um
I
um I I anticipated that you were going
to go ahead and give me a raise based on
the way you said that
um and if you're not going to I'm going
to let you know that that I'm going to
be leaving soon
okay
all right he's such a nice man and
that's the other thing that it's keeping
no he's not
nice men do what they say they're gonna
do bingo
yeah that's true that is true that's
passive aggressive is what he is
right and my husband has been telling me
that I need to go and look for something
different because yeah you know you know
what I'll change my mind I wouldn't even
I wouldn't even tell him I would just go
look for a job yeah you can yeah you're
not going to fix this guy you need to
leave you can find another job that you
enjoy that you love the people that the
person that you work for is a is a nice
man or a good person that exists in
other scenarios besides the one it this
is just the one you're most familiar
with and the one that you're used to so
don't let that make you think oh I'll
never be able to find something like
this a good again you might find
something better and you probably will
you'll probably find a better situation
lay out what you want I want hours I
want this kind of money and I'd like to
have benefits and then start looking for
that and I think you're going to find it
in two weeks
okay and I want to say thank you to your
plan because honestly right now I'm in a
great situation that I can pick and
choose what I'm going to do we have no
debt I only we have a house to pay off
and that's exact that's why I want to
work I want to work I want to pay off
the house faster if I work and I want
benefits I want to have a 401k through
an employer even though I have my own
opened up already I would still like to
have Devil's benefit well you know it
kind of has come down to
um
you have served for 10 years with no uh
without them giving you the items that
give you dignity okay for you that 401k
and the occasional tip of the Hat even
if it's a diamond hour at least it's a
raise just someone someone saying you're
doing a good job
[Music]
physically saying that not just giving
the words to it
um right and so uh yeah it's
um
yeah I mean I could talk about how to
ask for a raise and how to negotiate and
all those kinds of things but I don't
think I would here I'm with your husband
I think it's time to leave I think I'm
gonna go look for something else and uh
because I mean you've got this breakdown
if I'm you I've got a breakdown of trust
now in addition to the other things and
so um and you're just so sweet and every
there's just no there's no conflict or
drama in the air or uh uh actively out
there in front of you so you feel like
it's all safe but there is conflict and
drama under the surface here
and it's it's just not bubbled up
I think that she's probably done a great
job at work but if for some reason she
was doing a crap job at work and they
didn't think she was worth giving a
raise then that's still a leadership
problem they should have had a
conversation they should have said so on
either side of this pendulum which again
I don't I think that you probably did an
exceptional job at work it's just not
good it's bad business 10 years 10 years
not even 10 cents
not even not even a nickel not even
though
get out get out while you can yeah let's
go find something else hon I think I
think you'll be happier in the Long Haul
you just need someone to work should
have dignity to it yes and you have to
give dignity to it in the organization
that you're in it's that it's not hard
you just have to do it this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
all right
Jade warshaw Ramsay personality is my
co-host today hey we kicked off our
Building Wealth live event tour in
January here in Nashville and meeting
you guys in person was a lot of fun hey
we're hitting the road again in two
weeks and we want to see you there don't
miss your chance to see our team of
Ramsay personalities and me live in
person for Building Wealth 2023.
February 16th two weeks I'll be in
Indianapolis with Rachel Cruz George
Campbell and Jade warshaw and then we're
heading to Austin Texas February 23rd
the next week with Ken Coleman Dr John
deloney and Jade Warsaw April 24th I'll
be in Salt Lake City with Rachel Cruz
George Campbell and Christina Ellis and
our final stop of the tour is Anaheim on
May 2nd with me Ken Coleman Dr John
deloney and Christine Ellis tickets are
only 49 dollars you can get a four pack
for a hundred and seventy five dollars
these typically sell out completely they
did all last fall and uh well
Indianapolis still got a couple seats
left and uh not not normal for two weeks
out but if you want to come get in there
uh same thing for uh Austin Texas the
you can still get tickets but not for
long there's just a few left so
ramseysolutions.com events is where you
get your tickets
ramseysolutions.com
events our question of the day comes
from Teresa in the Ramsey Baby Steps
Community which is a community of uh
it's approaching a million people now on
Facebook a private Facebook Community
the Ramsey Baby Steps Community you can
join it Jade yep question of the day she
says can you explain the zero based
budget versus having margin in my
checking account how do I budget to zero
yet still have money left over as a
cushion in my account I probably
shouldn't actually have zero in the
account should I
I love this question no you should not
have zero in your account so when it
comes to zero based budgeting the whole
idea there is that you're giving every
dollar an assignment all right you're
not gonna just you know Let it Fly and
just say well I've got you know four
thousand dollars to budget and I'm just
gonna budget you know the stuff that
matters no you budget every dollar and
what is very important to do is make
sure that you have a line item that is
some sort of a cushion or you know a
category so that you're not totally at
zero because what if something happens
what if you know Grandma's birthday pops
up you know you don't want to just have
zero right so I keep a line item that's
like you know a little cushion so that
you're not at zero but that money does
have a purpose yeah zero based applies
not to you the balance of your account
it applies to your income
so when you get your paycheck
it should be spent on paper 100 percent
before you get your paycheck every
dollar have an assignment now if you
leave a hundred bucks or 200 bucks in
your checking account
then you add your income to it and you
spend all your income they'll still be
200 in the checking account so you've
still got a baseline in there right you
can do it that way or you can Reign or
the line item in the budget either one
if you want but you're right do you you
are right
um Teresa do not take your bank account
to zero yeah do give every one of your
dollars a name
see the thing is this most people uh
wonder where their money went
instead of telling you what to do and my
friend John Maxwell says a budget is
people telling their money what to do
instead of wondering where it went it's
that simple Giuseppe is with us in New
York City hi Giuseppe what's up
hi Dave how are you today better than I
deserve how can I help
I'm good
um I have a question I have a Toyota
Corolla uh SE Edition I guess you can
say
um I bought the car in 2020 it hasn't
been a a financial burden for me I've
been making my payments on time if early
my normal payment is 325 I pay 500
um but the funny thing is is I have all
the money to pay off this car right now
and I don't know what has been stopping
me to just write a check and pay it off
today I just paid off a credit card for
something that was a stupid debt as you
like to call it and um my goal really in
the future is to buy myself a condo it's
always been one of my dreams and I know
I'm not going to get there if I have
this car payment in front of me
um I live with my parents
um I'm 32 and I just don't know what's
stopping me from paying this debt
what is stopping you from paying the
debt if you want to pay it and you have
the cash to pay it pay it
I mean here's the thing I feel like
you've got a lot of
things in front of you that you want to
do so let's just take it in order and
and and get ourselves together so if
you've got money set aside how much
money do you have set aside
um well the car is about 11 500 I owe
and I have about close to maybe 18 five
saved already all right so we'll walk
through the baby steps so the way we
teach here is a series of of baby steps
that we walk through in order so the
first one would be having a thousand
dollars saved as a starter emergency
fund so for this purpose I would set a
thousand dollars aside that leaves you
with seventeen thousand and now we get
into your debt which is baby step two
we're paying off all of our debt except
a mortgage
um so how much debt do you have total
not just the Corolla
um
well I just paid off a credit card that
was about 1400. all right that one's
gone that's gone and I think I owe like
127 right now on one of my credit cards
and I actually recently just paid it off
yesterday so that one's gone okay yeah
so I think I'm for right now I'm credit
card debt free all your debt not just
your credit cards I want to know how
much total debt you have
the car is about eleven thousand five
right and then no more credit cards so
just a car okay no student loans nothing
like that right oh okay so we've got the
thousand dollars set aside and then out
of the 17 000 remaining we're gonna take
11 500 and pay off the Corolla right
okay and then from then we're going to
go to baby step three which is to have
three to six months saved now for you
what does that look like three to six
months of of expenses I know you said
you're living with your parents so what
does that look like
uh well I the thing is I work I work
whenever I possibly can I work for
Amazon delivery
um and that has been an up and down
battle because right but what would it
take for you to have three to six months
of expenses saved based off of your
lifestyle
it wouldn't take that long because I'm a
very good you almost have it yeah I mean
you've already got six thousand left six
or seven thousand dollars laying around
and you don't really have any expenses
at this point yeah I really don't yeah
so if your goal is to get a house and
your goal is to get a more stable career
than Amazon delivery uh the credit cards
are in your way the car payments are in
your way you need to get scissors out
and have plastic surgery this afternoon
my man chop those cards up and you need
to get on a cash basis for operating
your life and with no no car payments
anymore because you're going to pay them
off when you get off the phone right now
then you're going to pile up as much
cash as you can pile up beyond your
emergency fund to get your down payment
moving towards your house and help you
make the transition into the career
so the problem is um
there's a lot of things in your life
that you're doing at 70 percent
and I want you to turn it up to a
hundred
you seventy percent want to get out of
debt you 70 percent are working towards
buying a house use 70 are working on
your career and it's time for you to a
lot of fire under your butt and start
taking these things to a ten so write a
check today
pay off the car cut up the credit cards
get a debit card don't spend money you
don't have you're not in Congress and
then get your butt in gear on your
career get your butt in gear and go get
you a place to live and go have a life
yeah and the place to live doesn't you
don't have to we're not talking about
spending years more in your parents
house saving up money to get a really
short period of time yes time for you to
get in gear yes on a bunch of things
here really get in gear I mean go hard
yeah it's time to go hard because you're
you're getting mediocre results in every
area of your life because you're playing
at seven instead of playing at ten and I
want you to play for the freaking Super
Bowl man I want you to go for it because
you got that inside of you
thank you for calling in sir hey if you
like this show the best thing you can do
for us is leave a five-star review mama
said if you ain't got nothing nice to
say don't say nothing at all
share the show share it on uh
uh Spotify on Apple share it on YouTube
and subscribe if you're in if you're
listening as a podcaster or on YouTube
subscribe it helps the algorithm it
helps lead people to the show you are
our number one way of spreading the word
and as of today we've had one billion
YouTube views and one billion podcast
downloads thank you America
[Music]
foreign
Jade warshaw Ramsay personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America in the lobby of EMZ Solutions on
the debt free stage
Peter and Maria are with us hey guys how
are you hey Dave we're doing great
welcome where you guys live Kennesaw
Georgia just outside of Atlanta just
down the road here not far good to have
you guys welcome I appreciate you being
here how much debt did you pay off it
was just under a hundred thousand
dollars around 98 000. okay and how long
did this take just under three years
okay and your range of income during
that time we were around the 150 000 to
160 000. cool what do you all do for a
living I'm in sales and I'm a flight
attendant for a major U.S airline
awesome very cool good for you guys what
kind of debt was the hundred thousand
there were a lot of normal it was two
cars we had student loans some credit
card and then some home repairs
normal indeed you were normal yeah
normal sucks and you had it down yeah
that's good so how long you guys been
married three years November was three
years ah so you got married and went on
the game plan yes tell me the story how
this happens go ahead Pete so we were in
a marriage prep and uh Deacon Gary
giving you a shout out here was doing
our marriage prep and I was in a
transition of jobs I wasn't really
making as what I thought I should be and
so transitioning into a new job into
sales and I was just stressed I was
anxious about money I was nervous and
worried and and I asked him one day
after our session I was like I'm just
I'm worried about this and he just said
couple words he said check out Dave
Ramsey so I found your your podcast and
just started listening on Spotify and
that's it and then just started I keep
listening this is before we got married
so it wasn't until probably a couple
months after we got married that I found
out about Dave Ramsey uh-oh he kept it a
secret I was in David on you after it
was too late I was a Dave daughter for a
long time we were not uh on the same
page at first so no wonder he sprung it
on you but I always told Pete I don't I
don't always trust Dave but I trust you
oh wow
oh mic drop I like it so we had a lot of
really
um really like tough conversations we
learned a lot about each other like what
our um childhoods were like like
surrounding money you know different
ways our family handled money growing up
and um did you read Rachel's book on
that not yet called know yourself know
your money and she goes into all the
family history it's very good okay so
that's interesting we finally I ca I got
on the same page as Pete and I think
that's when we just really started
steamrolling and um it was about two
months after marriage we got back from
our honeymoon and and really just hit
the ball around we knew we bought a new
car and then we realized that we really
got to get serious so it was creating a
budget and getting on the same page wow
so you did that one silly thing right
after getting married and then it was
like okay now now we go now we go
exactly so who's the spender is that you
Maria yeah it was me yeah I had to to I
always felt like my sacrifice was bigger
because I had to cut back on spending
but in the end we realized that we um we
were both really contributing
you know we each had strengths and when
it was hard for me he would encourage me
and when it was you know something he
wanted to spend on I had to we had to
redirect each other a lot we kind of had
some tough things outside of paying off
debt that um
kind of coincided with what we were
going through my mom moved in with us
she lived with us for about a year and a
half after like right probably within
the first six months that we got wow
brand new marriage and your
mother-in-law moves
um that's a lot we suffered five
miscarriages during this time and
um yeah I mean anytime you're going
through grief sometimes spending money
it would have felt really good to add
something to the house or
um buy new furniture or whatever but it
you know paying off debt was like great
but everything else that kind of Spilled
Out into all the different parts of our
life and in the way our relationship
grew through this process is really kind
of like we could have never imagined it
yeah did I did I did I accidentally hear
you say it's valuable to learn the
process grief without and do it properly
without improperly doing it yeah it kind
of forced us to come together and
communicate instead of go to Target yeah
exactly our first three years of
marriage definitely were not normal by
any means and it was definitely
difficult it was very easy to just say
oh we don't want to do this anymore it's
just go back to the way we were doing
things but we had to work together it
really brought us closer what was your
what what was your why what kept you
going forward because like you said I
mean to your point many people may have
quit maybe people many people may have
said you know well we'll come back to
this later but what made you continue
through Pete you can say yours and then
I'll give mine we started I started to
feel the the Peace and Freedom that came
every when we're doing the baby steps
and and knocking off those lowest debts
and once they were gone I started to
feel that freedom and so it just kept
getting bigger and bigger and that's
what I loved and and to have a household
where our future children will not
understand what debt is or even know
what it is that's that was my why amen
amen for me it was actually more um I I
volunteered in places and I've been
blessed with people who have been able
to give and you always say live like no
one else and give like no one else and I
want to be able to walk into our church
one day or into a Pregnancy Resource
Center and say look here's a check we
want to help so man amen yeah that's
beautiful yeah well those are both great
wise and they both coexist I mean that's
fabulous well done you guys thank you
who was cheering you on outside the two
of you
it was really just I mean Gary yeah
our families were supportive we didn't
have many many naysayers uh maybe the
not the biggest cheerleaders but they're
always like hell cool they're great yeah
but we really had to motivate each other
it was uh it was us too and and really
once we finally got on page together and
Maria we came together that's it just
was the big snowball from there what do
you tell people the key to getting out
of debt is you paid off a hundred
thousand dollars in the first 36 months
of your marriage and endured hardship
yes it you have to work together that
was it we had to know where our money
was going but we had to work together
and uh our first the first couple months
or maybe even the first year uh when
Maria didn't fully believe in the in the
baby steps we weren't making that much
progress but once we came together
officially there was nothing stopping it
I think setting a deadline is really
helpful too Pete wanted to be debt-free
by 30. and we hit it right on the mark
so that was big very good very cool good
for you guys so what about what
convinced you Maria to jump on board
after that that first year of struggle
a couple houses and
eventually tried a commercial real
estate it didn't work out it wasn't a
good fit but he had signed a contract
and in order to break that contract he
had to pay back some money
and
the idea of going to work
and coming home and handing over this
person about you know it was two
thousand dollars
um kind of made me sick like I was like
we've been working so hard to pay off
this money
we paid out like we had we had our
emergency fund we cash flowed the rest
and I said I'm never having debt again
in my life so I don't think she was able
to really see we finally had margin in
our budget all the money wasn't going to
a bank or some type of debt and then it
got mad yeah
I like it I'll do it every time
hey we got the live and give bundle for
you guys to say thank you for making the
trip to do your debt free scream here in
the lobby that's the uh Total Money
Makeover book and the baby steps
millionaires book both number one best
sellers and a membership to Financial
Peace University if you've been through
it or haven't been through it all of
those are for you to use or to give away
or both so thank you thank you guys for
being here very well done very proud of
y'all well done thanks Peter and Maria
Marietta Kennesaw Georgia 100 000 paid
off in three years making 150 to 160.
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
that's how it's done
if you start your marriage that way boy
do you set yourself up to win powerful
powerful guys rock stars heroes well
done this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
21 now to him who is able to do far more
abundantly than all that we ask or think
according to the power at work within us
to him be the glory in the church and in
Christ Jesus throughout all generations
forever and ever amen
Dr May Jameson I don't know if I'm
pronouncing that right the first
African-American female astronaut said
never be limited by other people's
limited imaginations that's a good one
like that open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five Nick is
in Kansas City hey Nick welcome to the
Ramsay show
hello hey what's up
um uh well I had kind of a weird
question okay so uh I've been work I've
been working for my company for a pretty
long time I don't want to get real
specific but it's a construction company
and the owner of my company I'm pretty
high up on the Chain I'm basically
running the place now but um
he's offered to
sell the company to me
and I've talked to a few different
people and nobody really wants to talk
to me about it
and I don't really understand why I'm
sorry talk to you about what
uh it seems like they only want they
want to talk like I've talked to my
banker and he's like I really can't help
you unless I talk to him I want to know
what he wants and I'm like well
I I don't really know how to facilitate
my situation further because I want to
know more about the process that your
Banker doesn't have to talk to him
that's absolute bull crap
yeah your Banker's blowing you off
yeah so I don't know I mean where do I
need to go who do I need to who do I
need to talk to to get more information
well we can talk about it a minute here
um there there may be some uh uh some
small business mentors in the area you
may find someone in a construction
company of similar size in another city
that you could call up and ask and just
say hey I'm we're similar size over here
this guy's talking about selling to me
would you give me five minutes on the
phone and talk to the owner of it and go
what would you do and asks other people
in the same industry what's he how much
does he want for it
well I would think that the company is
probably worth as a whole probably
around six to six million dollars why do
you think that
uh uh I've been working there a pretty
long time and I know how much it's worth
no let that no you don't you just know
what it makes
where did you where did you get that
valuation I would say that there's
probably about two million dollars worth
of work on the books um I'd say within
the assets of the company and say
there's probably four million okay
that's not that's not how you value a
company
okay okay there's three ways you can
value a company one of them is the
multiplier of your gross revenues and
that won't work in this situation the
second way you can value a company is a
multiple a cap rate on the actual net
profit after all bills are paid the
actual net profit
as a multiple okay three it would either
be four or five times that number which
would be a 20 or a 25 rate of return for
the investor buying it and you would not
pay any more than a three or a five
multiple of net profit in this case the
third way you can value it is Book value
which is what happens if you close it
and you sell off the assets
but you don't add the assets to the
income to create the value
okay you're doubling up the value then
so all the assets totaled up the the
equipment the inventory that kind of
stuff what are the actual assets the
hard assets worth do you think roughly
you said you said four million didn't
you
I'd say the hard assets all the
equipment and everything
2 million okay so that's what it's worth
if you close it
he can get that just selling off the
stuff so usually Book value is is the is
the bottom line cheapest price of
business is worth it's worth at least
that
okay because we can close it and do that
then so it's probably really worth about
four or five times the net profit not
the gross not two million dollars on the
books or four million dollars on the
books of work because the work doesn't
make profit all of it it's not 100
profit
right so and you probably don't know
what the hardcore bottom line profit is
do you
no that's pretty tight yeah that's his
that's on his tax return
yeah he's gonna tell you that or he's
not going to sell you the company
well at some point he's going to have to
get a little deeper in conversation
you're going to have to get that number
or he's not going to buy it no one's
going to buy this company unless they
get that number nobody right he can't
sell it nobody I wouldn't touch it with
a 10-foot pole and if he tells me it's
not all on his tax returns that means
he's a liar now I really don't trust him
okay pretty nice guy so I don't care if
he's a nice guy or not that's like lots
of nice guys
either so the the thing is this then uh
you you guys are doing gross revenue how
much construction work a year
oh man
you said you had four million on the
books right
yeah
so are you doing are you doing 12
million a year
at least yeah all right and so if you're
on a 10 margin you're making a million
dollars a year
profit I'm gonna guess yeah okay and if
we did four times at the building the
thing's worth four million which if
you've got assets of two that's probably
about right
so if it's a million dollar profit and
we said 25 percent rate of return that's
four times so it would be worth about
four million you don't even you can't
get close to four million dollars
yourself can you
no okay so here's how you here's how
you're going to structure if you find
all of this out and if you get down to
the bottom of it and if it were four
million dollars here's how you structure
it without going to the stupid Banker
because apparently he's not going to be
any help
um now what I what I would do is tell
the owner let's say we find all of that
out and my example turns out to be true
to so you and I can talk through it it
may not be exactly that okay but if you
find out it's a million dollar profit so
the thing's probably worth about 4
million and you agree on 4 million as a
price if he wants six million he's
overpriced
okay
but if he wants four million on a four
on a one million dollar profit that's
probably about right then you would say
all right here's what I will do
I will give you 100 of the profits after
I pay myself my old salary and you keep
paying yourself the old salary after you
become the owner and you give them 100
of the profits until he gets his four
million
then if profits are down you're not
bankrupt
but if you go Finance the stupid 4
million and oh wait a minute real estate
slows down oh wait a minute the FED
raises interest rates oh wait a minute
Biden drives the economy in a ditch
you're bankrupt
because you got to pay payments whether
they don't care if you're making a
profit at the bank they want their money
right so if you structure a deal based
on profit goes to him he's going to get
all his money in four years or less
because if you get more profitable after
he leaves you're going to still give him
all the profit after you pay your thing
until until you got him paid out at four
million dollars
the price doesn't change just the speed
at which you give him his monies changes
right that structure will get you
through this deal brother without you
getting your throat cut but be careful
so that's a great that's great for Nick
right because he's not going into debt
for it can you explain Dave is there a
benefit for the current business owner
to take a deal structured like that as
opposed to some guy who may have just
gone to the bank
well number one the likelihood of
someone being able to go to the bank to
buy that Business Without substantial
assets is almost zero okay Nick cannot
bank that I think as an employee with no
asset base they're not going to give him
100 financing on a construction company
when he's never owned a construction
company and he has nothing to put down
that's not a bankable deal bank's going
to look at that and go no if they would
do it they're stupid and they're good
they're getting ready to go down with
him that's right but they're not going
to do it okay so the only person that's
going to be a buyer for this is somebody
like me if I wanted to buy a
construction company I've got the money
to buy that right then I'm not giving
him four million dollars
ah because you're a cat I'm gonna write
a check and it's going to be two million
dollars
that's how this works okay hey if
you've questions I'm also hosting now
the entree leadership podcast uh you can
send them to entreeleadership.com ask
and be a part of that podcast with your
small business questions that puts us
out of the Ramsay show in the books
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
foreign
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]